this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
light good morning and welcome to the
ninth lecture of the winter School uh
today's lecture number nine is titled
Newtonian SpaceTime is
curved this may come as a
shock uh because you thought probably it
is isn't curved and indeed in the
standard formulation it is not the
question is whether this standard
formulation holds up of course it does
in a way but if we inspect the axioms
properly I would like to make the point
that Newtonian space time must be
considered curved and in fact that this
curvature absorbs the effect of a
gravitational force so that no longer
gravity can be considered a force let me
make my point let's in the
beginning oh as you see today is a
physics
lecture um so however we'll of course
use much of what we have learned
especially the autop parallel equation
and we start here by Newton's two laws
which I wrote down more or less like
Newton did um Newton didn't use formula
he made little drawings and he used
words but it's actually very carefully
worded so the first axim is a body on
which no Force acts moves uniformly
along a straight line and usually there
is the addition in an inertial
system and Newton 2 also has the
addition in an inertial system I did not
put that there because an inertial
system has something to do with choosing
coordinates but this statement is an
absolute statement a body on which no
Force acts moves uniformly along a
straight line we know what a straight
line is independent of our reference
system right or we can at least
formulate this today second deviation of
a body's motion from such uniform
straight motion so deviation today we
call this
acceleration is affected by a force so
this identifies there is a force present
but the force doesn't act just like this
it's reduced by a factor of the body's
reciprocal mass the inertial mass Mass
the bigger the body's inertial Mass the
less the same force will accelerate the
body right so this looks nice and um the
question is what do these axioms say we
can read both axium statements about
what a particle does under various
circumstances if no Force acts then the
axium tells us the particle moves
uniformly along a straight
line however if you read read the first
axim like a postulate of what a particle
does it is merely a special case of the
second axium because if in the second
axum I say the force is zero the force
vanishes then deviation of a body is
affected by a Vanishing Force reduced oh
so there is no deviation from the
straight uniform motion so if you read
the first axim like an axim that says
what the particle does it becomes the
special case Newton wasn't that naive he
didn't need to emphasize the special
case in an extra axium and the first
Axiom needs to be read therefore a
different way in order to have an
important role the role is the following
you assume that for some reason we'll
come to that you know that no Force
acts and then for such you use such
particles to experimentally
check what a straight line
is okay so imagine you're in outer space
there's absolutely no Force at all you
throw a stone and it does something and
your the first axim instructs you to say
Ah that's a straight line you're testing
the
geometry of
space that's the idea it's a measurement
prescription for
geometry so that's this
and then the second axum tells you if
that if then you have other particles on
which a force acts for instance because
they have charges and they react to some
Fields that's a modern Faraday point of
view then the second axium kicks
in so um let me remark first
remark first
axium in order to be
relevant
must be
read as a
measurement
prescription for the
geometry of space
and actually we'll add something behind
space later that's the first remark and
that makes a lot of sense because if in
science you talk about an
entity like geometry straight line then
you better Define what it is now you
might say that's obvious well it's
obvious on paper in mathematics what the
straight line is but is it obvious what
in nature a straight line is well Newton
recognizes this and um makes of it a
measurement prescription for straight
lines
however there is a second important fact
that one
observes in nature and that is that
gravity affects all
masses all massive
particles so if I have a massive
particle and there is nothing else in
the universe
well maybe if I consider that the self
interaction of the particle with itself
gravitationally doesn't matter maybe the
first axium can be realized but as soon
as I have a second particle in the
universe and I think of gravity as a
force which is the standard view then I
can no longer use this
particle in order to measure this the
geometry of
space why well there is another particle
somewhere another mass and in Newtonian
Theory all particles have mass and all
masses gravitate at arbitrary large
distance so if we have a universe with
already two
particles the first axium can no longer
be applied because it's assumption that
no Force acts can no longer be applied
we say ah come on we nevertheless we
never use use this anyway we mostly work
with this and it works fine the axum is
there it's very important to say what
straight line is if you don't know what
a straight line is you don't know what
the deviation from a straight line
is of course because we're already
educated we know ah straight line that's
a covariant derivative here or rather
the gamma symbols are being determined
by
this deviation oh that must be the
covariant derivative of a curve
maybe the coant derivative of the
tangent Vector to the curve in the
direction of the tangent Vector to the
curve you remember a straight line was
nabla v v down V on V equals zero well
acceleration deviation from that is is
nabl down v v is not equal to zero
that's a vector again because V was in
the coent derivative makes of this a v
okay so you see if you don't know what
the straight line is you don't know the
gamma symbols you can't calculate the
acceleration you need to know the
straight lines first because before you
can even start talking about this we'll
do this more precisely okay but that's
an important Insight but the point is if
gravity is also modeled as a force and
it acts on every
Mass you have a
problem so um since
gravity un
ially
acts on
every
particle um in a
universe and of course when Newton says
body we think particle in a universe
with at
least two
particles gravity
must
not be considered a
force if the first axum if Newton
1 is
supposed to
remain applicable
so we got a serious problem because we
don't know how to encode gravity other
than as a
force the first one to think about this
was
llas and it's the laas you
know laas is question
and laas was uh what was it
1749 to
1827 laas asked the following
question can gravity be encoded
question can gravity
be
encoded in a
curvature of
space
such that its
effect this such that its
effects
um
show if particles
under the
influence of no
other
Force so we are still in this situation
where we think gravity is a force but we
want to get rid of it uh if particles
under the influence of no other
Force are required are
postulated to move
along straight
lines straight
lines in
this
curved
space that's the
question and in some museums in some
science museums you see this there is
some throat like this and you put a coin
here and then you flip the coin then the
coin coin runs in here like this have
you seen that right so bowl shaped like
this now of course it spirals in because
of friction if we imer so this is a
curved two-dimensional surface if we
imagine we had no friction you have the
idea it goes around like this and if you
give it less energy it goes on such an
orbit and so on and there is and
intuition could this be the motion of
the planets around the Sun one dimension
higher that that's the rough idea and
um well the answer to La's question and
llas spent quite some while thinking
about this but we don't think about it
we use mathematics and it's a TW liner
uh laas the answer to La's question is a
resounding no no you cannot it's
absolutely impossible to come up with a
curved space such that this
works why do we do it then well because
it's instructive to see what doesn't
work because we can repair
it
proof so what is the standard view so
the the gravity is a force view gravity
is a force point of view
and I mean after all gravity is a force
point of view works pretty
well it just has this slight conceptual
difficulty which is tremendous if you
think about it so let's start with this
um that means you have mass times what
you call
acceleration this is not the
acceleration but let's not talk about it
right now that comes later mass time
acceleration equals the gravitational
force field and the gravitational force
field so this is at a point so it's the
eeve
formulation you have this and the gravit
if it's the gravitational force field
you know that it satisfies pance
equation pance equation is 4 Pi Newton
Conant G * row and this is the mass
density
of
matter in the
universe now you solve this equation
usually write the f as the minus the
gradient of the gravitational potential
then you have pance equation and pance
equation is the gravitational field
equation in Newtonian gravity because
depending on the masses around it
determines the gravitational force law
you need to solve this once you have it
you can plug it in here to study how a
particle under the
on which this Force acts it acts on all
the particles reacts
okay now the thing
is um well actually if I write it like
this I need to have a little F here and
there's a little F here and an M here
because the gravitational force is this
F the gravitational force is
proportional to the mass of the body on
which it acts that's very special
it's also proportional of the mass of
the body that produces it uh more
generally written here but it's also
proportional to the mass of the body on
which it acts which results in which
fact which results in the fact that you
can cancel out this mass of the body on
which it acts all together and there is
no more mention of the mass of the body
on which it
acts is this
true well Theory doesn't tell us let's
go to experiment yes this is called in
theory the weak
equivalence
principle but we can give it names all
day
long experiment
decides so we have here two things we
have a little feather and we have a
little bead
both are red okay now uh they're just
for fun they're in this tube um let me
start maybe
here
okay now you know what happens um I now
erect the tube in into the vertical
position and every day day experience
tells you uh the little bead will go
down like CH because it has a much
bigger mass than the feather we would
say the people on the street would say
you're probably already more educated in
physics and the feather will just fall
more slowly will be less accelerated
maybe because you think it has less Mass
well that's
a okay once
again so I mean the bead you don't see
you only hear when it arrives down here
and then you look at the
feather huh the bead Falls much faster
because they both started from zero
speed up here it must have been
accelerated more
strongly that's what you think but of
course this is can all be attributed to
the air resistance within the tube and
we'll demonstrate this now so uh
removing the air resistance by
evacuating the
tube for
so the tube has now been thank you the
tube has now been
evacuated
okay now we do the same experiment again
air resistance has been switched
off it's it's not true that the bead is
more strongly accelerated than the
feather they're both accelerated the
same okay within the error of
measurement here thank you very much ah
okay well next proof so we didn't just
exchange the tubes and and the bead and
so on it's the same
okay
right Tada okay
proce yes I have two questions yes one
is a concept conceptional one you
convinced me that we have a problem uh
there are two ways out of the problem
one is we want to keep up Newton's a
Newton's first AEL but the other one is
we could just dispose of it yes so why
do we
choose you could dispose of it and then
my next question would be what do you
mean by deviation from a straight line
and then you could refer to the straight
lines of ukian geometry then I asked you
why is the world why does the world
feature physical space feature a ukian
geometry and I think at that point you
say okay let's reinstate it and let's
see whether we can save it that
way it's a fully conservative approach
nothing I say goes against anything
that's written in Newton's principia it
goes a little bit about what people made
out of it afterwards by using
vectors yes second question so this uh
is the US so this is the example we
usually bring when we talk about uh
conser conservation of angular momentum
so this here okay so angular
momentum from thean point of view is
just a
momentum and in that sense say there is
if there is no force acting then I don't
have
but what I don't see is if I sit on the
particle why could I not say so
this why can't I say that okay um if if
you go around in a curved space like
this nobody said that if you attach an
additional frame and you return that the
frame still points in the same
direction so this is just the the um
this is the the the the Free Falling
motion here but you're probably thinking
like you can feel that you go around
here and you're like the centrifugal
force or something like this we'll come
to
this okay so anyway we experimentally
verify it and then we give it the grand
name weak equivalence principle which
then is great for philosophers without
experiments um you cancel this guy and
then you can make an approach towards an
answer to La's question you say ah aha
laas wants to interpret this which we
interpret as acceleration and force he
says well the equation is correct
because I mean this is numerically
checked to very great Precision if you
neglect relativistic effect so let's
assume the world the real world is
Newtonian that's the name of the game at
this level um and laas doesn't say
change the equation put an extra term
laas says let's interpret this equation
as an autop parallel
equation because that is the equation
for a straight line so take the F to the
other side and LA's question now takes
the form
laas
asks is
this
of is this of the
form xou do a alpha of T So Alpha runs
from 1 to three right three dimensional
return space is this of the form xou
Alpha plus gamma Alpha Beta
gamma uh at the points where you pass X
beta dot X gamma dot of T of T equals
Zer that's his question is Newton's
equation if there's the gravitational
force can this be
interpreted as an autop parallel
equation no it can't why because thisy
gamma can only depend on the X where you
are but what about these two velocity
factors here this could only be
interpreted as this for well not for
zero velocity well actually not really
for any velocity because if you have any
velocity you can have double the
velocity that's possible and you would
whatever choice you make for the gamas
in terms of the fs you can't make this
match because you can't get rid of the
effect of the X dots in this gamma
because the gamma only depends on X well
even if it depended on x dot it would be
very difficult to get rid of these
vectors here so the point is this simply
doesn't have the form of the autop
parallel equation that means one cannot
choose so
conclusion one
cannot
find
gamas
gamas such that
Newton's
equation for this case of the
gravitational force uh takes the
form of an autop
parallel but being able to find such
gamas would mean being able to find a
notion of straight
line that could absorb the effect we
usually attribute to a
force okay it's done laas also found
this not using the auto parallel
equation because he didn't have it he
spent several days thinking and he
realized there are other inconsistencies
which at the end of the day are this one
it is not
possible this standard example from
science museums is entirely wrong
entirely wrong you cannot curve space
that
way
now what can we do so we already learned
something from our knowledge of the auto
parallel equation from our understanding
that it describes straight
lines that gamma can be made in any
point but only this point equal to
zero
yes that's another
problem yeah but I would say then can do
it at least in this point well look if I
let this
fall and then say here it has a certain
acceleration I can make the acceleration
vanish there by going to the coordinate
system that falls with
it that's that and now you say I can
fall with it all the time can't I make
this all along the curve zero so well I
have to walk uh climb up here and then
jump down and let let myself fall let
this fall and then I will fall together
with with the chalk
okay the problem is the Earth is round
and if
somebody at the North Pole makes this
experiment and thinks of a coordinate
system that's falling with him he will
be able to transform a the gravitational
force apparently there where he is but
in this falling coordinate system what
if at the same time somebody makes the
same experiment down here in the system
of the falling guy up here this one will
not be transformed away this effect so a
homogeneous gravitational field like we
like it in standard examples can be
transformed away entirely come back to
that later but an inhomogeneous one
can't so but that has to do with your
question here how this can be
transformed away okay so this uh is
rather sobering but um in fact as so
often
laas didn't look carefully so the full
wisdom of Newton
1 takes us all the way to implement ll's
idea in a way that works and what laas
asked can we find a curvature of space
such that particles move along straight
lines he didn't read Newton 1 properly
Newton 1 talks about a straight line but
it talks about uniform motion along a
straight line not just motion along a
straight line
okay so the full wisdom of Newton 1 is
use
also the
information from Newton's first law
that
particles under the influence of No
Force move
uniformly so if I draw this uh in a
two-dimensional flat space say this is
uniform motion uh these are
equal amounts of time one would say
that's a straight line straight uniform
line this is also a straight line but uh
the motion described by this is not
uniform because it gets slower and
slower laas in his idea only implemented
this only
tried to
implement this and as it's often said in
research proposals it's a beginning
okay but if you but if you don't take
things really seriously you see starting
somehow if we can't make this work we
won't make anything work no uh you have
to take everything into account and then
we start talking um the question is
rather than drawing these pictures and
something that's very difficult to
explain to students at first is that a
curve is more than the set of it its
points a curve is the set of its points
and its parametri ation which makes
exactly the difference right well let's
make it easier for students uh let's
introduce the appropriate data structure
to capture this introduce the
appropriate
setting to
talk about the difference between these
two
difference um
easily and that is something you also
know from school you draw a space time
diagram uh if you have a harmonic
oscillator you did
this how does the position depend on
time uh well let's do this for a
one-dimensional world um say this is the
one-dimensional world here and now I
have a
straight uniform motion that looks in a
one dimension world like this agree and
I have a straight non-uniform motion
well you can in a onedimensional world
the motion is always straight but the
point is here the difference between
straight and
uniform now in rather than showing this
and remembering the
parameterization we attach a Time
axis and we do not introduce new data
but we just represent the data in
different fashion if these were
equal intervals of time then it's clear
how to translate these pictures uh this
one looks
like
so
so so and so on uh because every time I
arrived at this
interval it's like this agree that's
uniform straight Motion in one Dimension
well this is also straight motion one
dimension you but you could easy imagine
an extra Dimension it still runs along
the xaxis would be straight motion um
but again equal time intervals um would
lead you
to
have hang on a second equal time
intervals now we need
to uh hang on I'm
confused H equal I no this is less time
that's the point this is less time
I'm confused no it's the same time for
Less distance ah it looks like this
exactly it goes up I'm sorry this is not
getting slower I said here it's getting
slower it's getting faster of course no
it isn't I'm I'm
confused are you also confused
noeler is exchange ah of course of
course of course so yeah yeah yeah so
this is really so this is getting slower
and this is also getting slower because
in equal times it makes less
now so as a relativist this is a rather
embarrassing moment okay so we're trying
to cut it off the video okay because I
don't even have the excuse that in
relativity you you order the axes
differently well I have an excuse
because there are no axes but but that's
okay anyway so so you see the point the
the the inside is the
inside is um in space
time in space time if you attach time to
space and consider it an
entity this guy here is simply you can
ignore the parameterization because
nobody cares whether you now
parameterize this curve in space time in
the most crazy
manner because for every point where you
are you just look at this axis and you
know what time it is you no longer rely
on the parameter that par parameterizes
the SpaceTime curve because you stored
the information in the extra coordinate
you freed yourself from uh
parameterizing the curve in a certain
way because you stored the information
but even better in space time
uniform and
straight
motion where the uniform and straight
must be set because we always think
about time but in space time you don't
need to say uniform and straight Motion
in
space in space time this uniform and
straight Motion in space is
simply straight
motion no further questions asked so
this gives us a hint LA's idea might
work if you only look at straight lines
if you only want to implement straight
lines but it will work in space time in
Newtonian space time this has nothing to
do with
relativity it's just drawing what you
already Drew in school for the harmonic
oscillator it's not relativity it's just
representing the data you have in a
different fashion this goes one to one
okay but then we can use our ideas about
straight motion otherwise we would have
to invent new differential geometry that
implements straight in uniform motion it
can be done too but not in that way okay
so let's try
this so let's
try in space
time well uh the first thing we need we
need to convert the data into the right
form so um let X from R to R3
be a
particle
trajectory in
space so this is the usual picture and
now I claim you can convert this back
and forth into a world line that's just
a name a world line you could also call
the world line the history of the
particle because obviously
if you um if you look at the world line
of some particle you know its entire
story so you can
uh you can tell jokes in SpaceTime which
today are somewhat outdated for instance
uh in Newtonian SpaceTime this is the
joke Pope
Pope what is the
joke two popes meet okay so this is
nowadays possible but this is a joke in
space this a story you're telling a
story in space time okay so the the
world line somehow this joke never works
I don't know why anyway so you convert
from
this you convert this information into
that information very easily you assign
to each T now a quadruple of real
numbers a for truple where you just
reproduce what you already put in not a
problem and then you use the trajectory
you had before which of course
decomposes in three real functions that
is the world line of a particle uh and
that is of course the picture I drew
over there if you want a more elaborate
picture uh you can uh put here the Sun
at least a very massive body uh and you
may put here a very small body I don't
know me
and we know it does something like this
if it's ener is not too big otherwise it
will fly away in parabolic or hyperbolic
motion as a bound orbit that's what we
observe something like this in neonian
gravity it would be like that and so
this is the curve X but you know there
is kepas uh uh law of equal areas in
equal times and blah blah blah blah so
the parameterization here plays a role
but now you
may represent this in space time X1 X2
space time time and what is circular
motion elliptical motion down here in
space
time Becomes Of course
something I don't know whether the
picture is so good but it becomes a
spiral right it's a spiral and you can
look at every point where you are
okay but obviously if you're here you
can go back because you just project you
just forget the first component and you
get this curve back
there's nothing happening no new physics
no nothing is just a different way to
represent the uh history of a
particle that's
it that's all it
takes to make LA's idea work but in
space time why well first there is a
trivial implication from our
uh so the point is let's assume that on
this side let's
assume that X the little X we start on
the left hand side satisfies again uh
Newton's law uh concerning the
gravitational force such that I could
already um cancel the M let's assume
this so now we have a number of trivial
really trivial rewr
writings the first one has nothing to do
with this the first one is that I take
the zeroth component and this is just a
manner of numbering the components here
that I say this is the zeroth component
of this uh coordinate map and you see we
here all in charts I have only talked
about charts um and then you have and
this is not a Vector but this is uh this
capital x is just a world line
coordinates I just label them like this
and it's very clear that if
you take the time
derivative of the
x0 it's one because it's simply x0 of T
is T you take the derivative It's one oh
that's very simple and and then from
this it follows
immediately that if you take the second
time derivative
it is
zero of course the derivative of one is
zero so we keep this in mind and uh now
we write down a number of equations the
first one is this one this is simply
true right this is simply true now I
write down what is the time
derivative of the alpha components Alpha
runs from 1 to 3 what's the time
derivative of of the alpha components
all depends on T well uh you need to
look ah there it says because the x
capital the X Alphas are the small X
Alphas you can use this and if you use
this we can of course take it to the
other side
agree minus F Alpha of well this only
depends on the small X's but you can
also write in there the capital x is
strictly speaking it's a different
function because the function that
ignores its first entry well that's not
very deep let's name it like this equals
zero that's it that solves the
problem you say hang on how on Earth is
this going to solve the problem because
as far as one can see you still have the
same problem here and you just added an
equation how can that help well that
equation doesn't help it just doesn't
cause trouble we'll see in a second but
there is something that helps may this X
do0 is 1 so I can easily multiply here
with x do0 uh x0 do x0 dot right * 1 * 1
I did not change a
thing how is that supposed to help well
these two here these two equations are
perfectly equivalent to the following
set of equations X up a where a now runs
from 0 1 to 2 3 and here the alpha runs
only 1 2
3 x a double dot plus gamma AB b c
x.b x do c equal Z what is this this is
an autop parallel equation in space time
right it's an
auto
parallel equation in
Newtonian space time
and now you compare the two and you say
oh
yes
choosing in this chart I mean we're
always in a chart with coordinates so we
can choose gamas choosing gamma we read
it off what are the gamma zero if a is
zero what are all the gamas that have a
zero
up well they must all be zero because I
have plus Z here so gamma zero up
whatever is down at any point in this
space must be zero I read this off now
let's look at this one what do the gam
what do I have to how do I have to set
the gamas that have an alpha up well the
gamas that have an alpha
up if they have anything down that's
different from zero Alpha up say um one
one then it would produce a term X1 dot
X1 Dot and that's not good all of those
Alpha
up and beta gamma down or it even
suffices is zero but it even suffices if
one of the two down is zero but that
could also be the other
one they all must be
zero why because otherwise if we choose
them different different from zero terms
come up in this on this side that do not
have this
form so all the gamas are zero
only gamma up Alpha down Z down Zer that
must be chosen
as minus F
Alpha at each point oh nice alpha alpha
these indices are set now it makes sense
with the
indices so the claim is in the chart we
started with which is the start the
chart which in standard neutronium
mechanics is called the obvious chart or
the cartisian chart or whatever it
doesn't matter uh we play the game for a
time being until we made our point and
then we'll make it more clear in that
chart you have can choose gamas to be
given by minus the gravitation Force
divided by the mass it acts on so the
this little F and the others you choose
all
zero now you say hang on and that's the
question could asked could I transform
this away because this is just in one
chart right I could use the gamma
transformation law and we know even
though the gamma can be non zero in some
charts there may be a chart where it's
zero or there may not be it depends on
whether the curvature vanishes or not
you
remember the question is is this a
coordinate
artifact
question is this
a
coordinate
Choice
artifact the answer is
no since
we can calculate the reman
curvature and the reman curvature of
this of the connection defined this way
we can calculate it in that chart R
Alpha and the only non Vanishing
components only non Vanishing components
you can calculate the others and they
will all vanish the all only
nonvanishing
components are those minus Del beta F
Alpha in this chart and uh
probably we would rather write it like
this these are the only nonvanishing
components this is actually known as the
tidal Force tensor if you study how
tidal forces act you look you look at
this guy it's the title Force
tensor it's the hessan of the
gravitational it's minus the hessan of
the gravitational potential it doesn't
matter that's the guy uh and you can
calculate the z0 component of the REI
tensor you remember the rich
tensor Rich tensor uh
um is the contraction so that's the
components that I left is the
contraction here you go you contract the
first and the third index was on the
last tutorial sheet anyway it's a it's
sub information it's traced information
in here and the rid tensor is minus
Del well d by DX so here it doesn't
matter to write it so precisely because
uh we're he in these coordinates is
this but now you say oh my God we know
something about this guy because we
remember that we had Pon law
right P told us that minus Del Alpha f
Alpha is 4 Pi * Newton constant times
the mass density of the masses that
generate the gravitational force so this
is equal to 4 Pi Newton constant row
ah
interesting well interesting if you know
general
relativity because you could call this
the zer0 component of an energy momentum
tensor and then you got something like
r0 equals t0 0 okay uh so writing and
that is now really in a sense cheating
uh an energy momentum tensor uh writing
it like
um2 row or something like
this uh you get
r00
equals
16 Pi no 8 Pi G
t0 and these are is the F this is the
first of 10 gravitational equations that
Einstein postulated in
1912 Einstein in 1912 said in
relativistic physics where a few more
ideas come in but in relativistic
physics he said you have R A equals 8 Pi
g t
AB the point is this isn't entirely
correct but it's almost
correct SpaceTime Rich curvature he said
in 1912 is the energy momentum of matter
we'll come to this the point is this is
not far from what Pon law says Pon law
says that for the curvature of space
time in Newton
gravity
r0 is 8 Pi gt0 0 well that's cheating
because I set it to row but in
relativity if you have dust that's lots
of particles that don't interact and
only have mass it looks exactly like
this so Pon equation which you all know
makes you understand the basic idea of
Einstein's equations at least the old
form the not correct form there's an
extra term missing here that makes it
correct but that's another issue and
that has to do with relativity and
SpaceTime physics in relativistic
SpaceTime physics but Pon law the field
equation for gravity is right here and
because it's non zero in the absence of
masses in the absence in in the presence
of masses the curvature is not zero if
the curvature is not zero remember the
theorem there is no coordinate system
where the gamas all vanish
you have the Earth you make a
non-homogeneous gravitational field and
there is no system where you make for
every particle that you can think of
make the gamas vanish so it's not a
coordinate artifact it's not like oh
choose better coordinates and the effect
is there no it's not a coordinate and
wouldn't it be funny if it was a
coordinate artifact because coordinates
are in our mind but you feel whether you
accelerate or not okay so all fits
together okay so we have
this um and so the conclusion is uh
lass's
idea
conclusion LA's
works on space time neonian space time
oh by the way you see the gamas that
were nonzero so yet another remark
the gamas that were nonzero were
gamas that had time indices well here we
think of them as time indices has to do
something with this extra direction
right this shows it's not a curvature of
space for instance the reman tensor in
components Alpha Beta Gamma Delta
they're all zero where Alpha Beta Gamma
Delta run from 1 to three it's not a
curvature of space
the space time is not curved in the
space directions roughly speaking in
this neonian space time it's curved in
the extra Direction together with the
space you understand what I mean okay so
here you see it's really space time
curvature not space curvature but space
time curvature that works the only
one that's not
Vanishing is this one but that means not
all components of the reman tens are
vanish
yes right side is this certainly
transforms as a t on the left there's
point and
gamma gamma does not transform as a
tensor but the X double dot neither
thank you for the question so very good
question neither the velocity
theeler the velocity does the
acceleration doesn't well let me write
it down okay so question
what about the transformation
Behavior travle
behavior of left hand
side of X double dot Alpha no
a plus gamma AB c x.b x do c equal Z
well this guy here you may remember is
this
guy we calculated this so if you take
the derivative of the Velocity in the
direction of the velocity of a
curve the eighth component is this here
this is the eighth
component and this is again a vector
field along the curve and this guy is a
vector field which we call the
acceleration
a uh well a yes yeah it is a let me make
a fancier a because I also have an index
a this is the
acceleration
acceleration vector I told you the
acceleration is a vector the
acceleration is a vector but the second
derivative of the components of a curve
are
not the components of that acceleration
this belongs to a to and only the sum of
the two transform right and you know
these transform as vectors because the
velocity components we checked that
these do not and in the same way no in
the opposite way in which the gamas Do
Not transform as tensors as a one two
tensor in the opposite way this doesn't
transform as a vector as Vector
components and but the sum of the two
cancels the Troublesome terms and only
the combination deserves to be called
the
acceleration you can't say that's the
acceleration and that's an extra an
extra acceleration no this together is
the acceleration and of course it's
chart independent if you sit on a
rocket you feel whether you accelerated
or
not how crazy would it be if somebody
thinks another coordinate system and you
feel something
different it won't happen okay this
together is the
acceleration
okay
now we have thus
reformulated Newtonian Theory such that
gravity is a curvature of Newtonian
space time and the first axium now takes
the form particles under the influence
of No Force but gravity no longer counts
among them under no other the of no
other Force moves along has a world
line that is straight but a world line
is in space time end of message this is
Newton's first axium you don't say
uniformly straight in space you say
straight in space time the world line
grav and if you now have gravity and you
throw to Pi say that's the Earth right
small Earth if these two particles you
drop them and they will start doing this
right they will be convergence of these
lines that's another way you can
identify curvature that you that
geodesics that are originally
parallel start converging think of the
surface of a sphere you you go from the
equator up parallel now equator you go
up parallel but finally they meet okay
that's another effect that you have when
there's Cur it's called geodesic
deviation so we solved our problem we
just have to accept that space time is
curved but your space is still nice and
flat but space time is curved and the
first axim can be put into
practice Case Closed um up to the point
that of course we have a terrible
coordinate dependent formulation here
all was with components what is the real
structure behind that um so that's
section
three adequate a sketch or the
foundations because I I have no time to
do this all uh the
foundations of the geometric
formulation of Newton's axioms and again
this is not new
physics this is just what Newton wrote
down in
words implemented properly with the
mathematics that makes it work rather
than that the mathematics that seem
seems to make it work okay so uh the key
definition I just catch it and I tell
you where it goes but maybe you're able
to fill in uh the uh the following steps
yourself definition a Newtonian
SpaceTime so this is now we we we have a
new start okay so this is just in our
mind this change our philosophy a little
and now we start talking seriously okay
so a Newtonian
SpaceTime is a quintuple of
structures and about every single
structure here Newton talks okay uh it's
a set with a topology continuous curves
and so on it's smooth we can take talk
about derivatives we have a coent
derivative of course we do because
Newton talks about straight lines uh
uniform straight lines we translate this
into straight lines in space time um and
Newton also
talks insistently on something called
absolute time we have an absolute time
T
where M
OA is a four
dimensional smooth
manifold a four dimension smooth that
has no that has no direction this is
space and this is time there's a danger
in the word SpaceTime the danger in the
word SpaceTime is is that you misspell
it uh you could misspell it like this
space plus time this is not space time
space time is one thing in which at
first you cannot distinguish between
space in time it's just four di like the
sphere the sphere is two dimensional but
you wouldn't say uh where's One
Direction over the other well
okay space time and only you start with
this and then you make have a derived
notion under certain circumstances what
is space and what is time okay so space
time is a four-dimensional manifold
don't think you already know what it is
delete all your memory so four
dimensional space time with a coant
derivative and and this this is this and
T this is clear what this is a coant
derivative and T is a smooth function on
the manifold so absolute time is a
smooth function T from M to R is a
smooth function
and Newton says
things he says two things which we
convert into aums into requirements I
should say
satisfying which we convert into axioms
for these two
structures one thing Newton says is that
um there is
absolute
space that's what Newton says there is
an absolute
space um this will take the following
form you say oh we didn't provide for
absolute space we only provideed for an
absolute time whatever it
is but it can be derived there is
absolute
space is this
it's the requirement that the gradient
of the absolute time function doesn't
vanish anywhere it's
nonzero all on the manifold so if you
take it at a point
P at every point of the manifold you
require that this absolute time function
has non Vanishing
gradient what does it have to do with
this absolute
space so this is no longer part of the
axium but that's something that follows
from it you define absolute
space s to it's absolute space at time
to Absolute space at time to is the set
of all the points of the man of the four
dimensional
manifold that satisfy the condition that
t of the point well if T is a smooth
function function on the manifold then
every Point can be assigned at T of P
every point of the manifold every event
in space time is given a
time a universal clock time okay um and
the space the absolute space to at time
TOA is the collection of all the points
that have the time label to as uh this
says and then it follows by this DT non
zero it follows that the entire manifold
is a disjoint Union and the
disjoint comes from this is a disjoint
Union of all these
spaces or in other words if you like
pictures if I do a three if I do a
three-dimensional space Tye because I
can't draw a four-dimensional
one SpaceTime foliates
foliates in all of these uh
S1
s32 s pi and so on right it foliates in
all these spaces and the universal clock
gives the same time for all these points
here as long as this is a smooth
function and the gradient vanishes if
the gradient would vanish you would have
um so you look at it from the side
so this would be S1 and this would be uh
s a little later if it would vanish for
quite a while S2 uh they would intersect
here right that would be a point where
uh if these are Level lines of the uh
Global time function of the absolute
time functions at this point p uh there
would be a problem therefore we exclude
that okay so aha so this requ innocent
requirement on the absolute time yields
you a notion of absolute space and of
course that's how we think of space time
there are spaces stacked together to
give space time he said but they're
stacked together in a in a strange way I
mean why why are they like wobbly well
what do you mean by wobbly have we
talked about shape yet no we haven't
okay good then Newton goes on and he
says things like
time flows uniformly
so absolute time he
says
absolute time flows uniformly Newton
says what does that mean with 1 second
per
second right I mean what is that
supposed to mean where if you want to be
clear about it you say that the coant
derivative of the
gradient vanishes everywhere so if you
put here an X for any X this is again
the zero Co Vector field you say this is
zero at all points of the
manifold so
everywhere it's already written as a
field
equation this means absolute time flows
uniformly how do we understand that this
means absolute time flows uniformly
let's see in a second okay question
yes yes that's um if there's if this is
open here so um you could put uh d by
dxa here in any coordinate system on the
manifold uh and then you take the be
component and then because this is C
Infinity linear and certainly C Infinity
linear if I put something here this
would be a02 tensor
field so if I leave this slot
unfilled then this is a
02 tensor
field and I can require that to be the
zero tensor field of that type if you
don't like it in this form we'll do it
in coordinate form a little later but I
maintain that this equation is good and
this is an equal sign on the space of 0
to tensor
Fields anyway so let's do this in
coordinates in a second yes got
problematic point would it correspond to
saying that time stop
yes time time would here time would
would stop for a while right because um
yeah that's what the gradient is no if
if you draw the level surfaces if the
gradient gets
uh yeah you know if this goes together
yeah that's right time time would stop
here that's
correct and and that's of course
meaningless that that's it's not what we
want in physics but it could be if we
just say it's a smooth function so we
have these two AXS you see this is a
compatibility Axiom because it relates
these two things Newton talks about so
eloquently but um that's sometimes uh a
matter of a heated debate what exactly
this means well this is well a proposal
this is a clear formulation of what it
means and this you can make work okay so
um well if you bear with me for 10 more
minutes I can sketch a little bit how it
goes from here on but I won't do the
full thing um because actually my main
point for the purpose of these lectures
was made before that you can view
gravity as a curvature of space time
already in Newtonian mechanics okay uh
and that this viewing gravity as a
curvature of space time even within
neonian mechanics is not just an
alternative formulation which of course
is the more uh uh agreable view point of
view to take but really if you look at
the first a you say what other choice do
I have okay anyway that will be exactly
the philosophical point of view the
approach in general relativity later and
I wanted to show to you that already in
Newtonian gravity that gravity effects
or can be understood as a curvature of
space time has all to do with
gravity and very little or rather
nothing to do with relativity it's not
relativity that forces us to space time
as far as gravity concerned it's gravity
itself and the understanding of the
relation between geometry and gravity
and all of that okay so I think that's
the most important lesson in there for a
theory Builder um but anyway so now we
have this uh nice
definition and
um well now we can make a
definitions
definition a
vector X in some TPM in
SpaceTime is called
called uh a future
directed if the application of the
absolute time function to it yields a
number greater than
zero the vector is called spatial it's a
spatial Vector in the sense of absolute
space if the application of the gradient
of the absolute time function is zero
and it's called past
directed if you guess it DT of X is less
than zero what does that mean
picture you have the level surfaces of
your absolute time function which are
called the absolute space at the various
times and you now take a point in one
such absolute space which however is
also a point in space time and you have
a SpaceTime Vector say this one well now
it depends on whether this is S2 and
this is S1 because then time increased
from here to here and then this
one applied the gradient of the absolute
time function which is a co- Vector
applied Co Vector field applied to this
Vector at this point yields a positive
number so this guy is future
directed um whereas uh a vector that
points what we intuitively would call
Tang to the
surface this guy this is
spatial well of course it's a tangent
Vector to the level surface of this of
course the gradient on the tangent
Vector of a level surface vanishes this
this old theorem and if you had a vector
pointing here this would be a past
pointing or a past
directed Vector right okay so uh the
impact of this is um definition
or rather
postulate or rather Newton's first
law Newton
1 it's still Newton one it says nothing
different it says um the world
line World line of a
particle under the
influence of No
Force and I mind you again gravity isn't
one
anyway in this view isn't one
anyway
is a future
directed a future
directed autop
parallel with respect to the nabler we
have on space time and a future directed
curve is a curve that
has as its tangent vectors at every
point a future directed velocity okay so
a future directed Auto parallel means
that's an auto parallel so you have
nabla V World line X on world line X
zero that's Auto parallel no Force
acceleration is zero and you have that
DT of the velocity is greater than zero
everywhere of course the particle runs
into the future and not into the
past in SpaceTime you need to make the
distinction between future and past
right
you okay that is this that's F Newton's
first law no more funny
talk now there is an interesting
question about what this formulation can
give you other than a nice formulation
of Newton 2 which I also write down in
short
form Newton
2 is simply the
acceleration of a world line which is of
course this guy if it was Zero it's
unaccelerated uh is a gravitational
force H sorry is a force not a
gravitation not gravitational is a force
so
where f
is a
spatial Vector
field because a force is only supposed
to accelerate you in the spatial
directions okay so you have you can
prescribe a vector field it's only a
force if it's a spatial Vector field
then you have this that's Newton's
Second Law and if you like if you like
it's m * the acceleration is the force
nobody said that's wrong I only said the
acceleration is not X double
dot
okay so that's uh Newton Second
Law now
um let me introduce one more piece of uh
one more idea but that's more or less
just a
convention and then we have
another I believe good
Insight
convention we have this absolute time
function right it's given to us as part
of the structure of the
manifold the convention would be
restrict attention but that's really a
convention you don't need to do this is
just incredibly practical restrict
attention
to
atlases a
stratified we call them a stratified
Atlas to adlas a
stratified um whose chart whose charts
ux have the
property and now of course if you're a
geometer and you say oh you know what
you can require on your charts whatever
you like as long as they still cover the
manifold I don't care about your charts
because your charts are in your head so
this is not a real really a convention
let's only think of those charts because
okay uh that have the property that the
zero you know that this chart map comes
in a on a four-dimensional manifold in
terms of three coordinate functions
right and so on uh that have the
property that the zero coord coate
function coincides with the absolute
time function why can you do this well
the absolute time function is defined on
all of M so you can always take the
Restriction to a chart domain U because
the other coordinates might not be
defined all on all of them but so the x0
which is defined on U is just the
absolute time FR that exists everywhere
globally by axium by Newton's talk um
let's do that it's just clever because
otherwise you have an atlas you can
choose an atlas that disobeys this
structure and all the formula are right
it's just the formula becomes simpler if
you make this choice and because you
have the data why not use it okay to
make life simple but it's really make to
make life simple nothing depends on it
okay very important a stratified Atlas
um and in the stratified Atlas we can
now
evaluate this guy with some inside uh
you know what this is this guy we set is
zero uh that is the time flows uniformly
torque absolute time flows uniformly
nice what does it mean in a stratified
Atlas well uh it means this guy here is
of course then just the dx0 you
agree uh in any direction so for any d
by DX a a running from 1
from 0 to three right is zero but this
guy is because there's the DX it's the
minus gamma symbol you remember from
yesterday this is minus the Gamma or day
before yesterday this is minus the gamma
symbol and it has the index a down here
this zero comes to lie here and there is
another B here because the whole thing
is a one form field so there's the other
B okay so you see that all the gamas
whatever is down from 0 to three all the
gamas with an index zero
up vanish that is what this thing says
in a stratified Atlas in a
non-stratified
atlas you get extra terms but they're
all coordinate artifacts because you
could go to a stratified Atlas okay you
can always do that because that is
always a global function and then these
guys vanish now let's use this and let's
evaluate what Newton 2 says so let's
evaluate in a
chart
ux of a
stratified
Atlas a
strat so actually everything is said
there is nothing more to be said what
I'm going to do now reconnects you with
chart physics which we're used to and
we'll recognize terms we always
interpret it in a I would say rather
peculiar
manner Newton's second
axium uh Newton
2 what is Newton 2 Newton 2 says nabla
velocity of the world line velocity of
the world line is f by m right that's
what Newton 2 says now let's write this
in
coordinates um in the
chart this takes the following form
X I do the zero component separately
because then I can discuss it better x0
now did I say anything about how the
world lines are to be parameterized no
said a world line is a future directed
curve right um that satisfies this also
here Newton 2 says a x is a future
directed
curve like in the first axum right and
then this is true um I didn't say
anything about the parameterization you
so you could have chosen any let's call
it Lambda and then the autop parallel
equation says take the x0 component
deriv it twice with respect to Lambda
then comes gamma 0 a x a prime XB Prime
equal Z with respect to whatever
parameter you chose do you lose
information about time no you go to the
point you evaluate the point with the
absolute time function you have the time
whatever your parameter chosen now I
write the other three all at once with
Alpha so Alpha is from 1 to three so
Greek indices always run from one to
three and Latin indices from zero to
three x Alpha double Prime plus and now
I split up what happens here so I have
the alpha now like here the alpha now I
have ab x a prime XB Prime but I like to
resolve this Einstein summation
convention somewhat I could have that
these two guys are just okay now I call
them Alpha Beta is not clever let's call
them um
CD CD okay so I now for the Alpha Gamma
Alpha I have they could be both indices
1 2 3 okay then I have here by extension
of the summation
convention this but then I forgot terms
okay I forgot the terms where I have
both of them zero I have x0 prime x0
prime okay but I still forgot terms I
forgot the terms where I have a beta
gamma down one is
uh 1 2 3 and one is zero so I have X
gamma prime x0 prime and I forgot yet
another ah I should have said something
I'm sorry I forgot something in the
axioms for Newtonian space please uh add
to the axium I'm
sorry add two
axium of
Newtonian space
time now I made a postulate on the T me
DT not equals Zer I made a postulate on
the compatibility of gamma and T NAA and
T me NAA DT is always zero and the third
one I forgot is a postate on the naer
alone nabler is torsion
free I'm sorry I forgot that naer is
torsion free one condition on the
absolute time one condition on uh the
coent derivative and one compatibility
condition between the two I'm sorry so
you have this but if it's torsion three
we still miss a term namely where the
first one is zero and the second one is
gamma but that is the same term if it's
symmetric down here so I get a factor of
two and I bet you all spend a lot of
time in your lectures on classical
mechanics deriving this
too ah and the right hand side is of
course not right here we have F Alpha
divided by m and there it's Z because
that's the F0 in a stratified Atlas F0
is of course zero because
DTF is
zero so this is Newton's second law
written out what on Earth do we learn
from that this isn't even time this is
an arbitrary
parameter well in a stratified Atlas
this guy goes
out so in a certified Atlas we can
immediately
conclude x0 dou Prime of the parameter
Lambda is zero meaning x0 of Lambda
equals a Lambda plus b for constants
AB
agree what is x0 x0 is T is X little x0
Z after the world line curve X
right of Lambda but that is T after X of
Lambda in a stratified
Atlas meaning the time of a point along
a curve runs proportionally to this
parameter Lambda the other way around
the time is given the time function and
the zeroth component which you say well
that I'm really not interested it in
that's just garbage and you remember
before we had this as the zeroth
equation uh we inherited this and it was
triv true and so on so you see in a
stratified Atlas what we did before in
the first part where we had a zero here
that's only true in a stratified Atlas
the point is the SpaceTime diagrams I
drew in the first part of this lecture I
already assumed I I cheated because I
said that's space and that's time let's
do this well I assumed that space
repeats itself like this
right in a stratified Atlas if this was
a chart picture it wouldn't but in a
stratified picture it also looks in a
chart Atlas like this so what I did was
right but now I understand why because I
already used the global time function in
order to define the
spatials uh the spaces yes confused we
started out with constructing our form
list in a way where we those Capital
gamma Z CD to zero because we started
with demanding that
you is valid that was the first part of
the lecture right yes the only
difference was that there were dots
instead of the primes so we said okay
let's demand that GMA has this property
of having mostly zeros now we say okay
let's formulate this in a manner yes
which has the mathematic that's right
and now we are happy to recover that the
gamas are zero no no no no no no no no
it's right so the the first half of the
talk until I started this section was
starting with what we always write down
and somehow working your way to an
understanding that you say somehow this
looks better but now we were always
caught in a sense of preconceptions of
superstition or of preconceptions about
charts and what it means means to have a
Newtonian space time this was rather
formulated in a vague manner in a
non-geometric manner always in charts
and we went up once we were there we had
some insight we say we need a proper
geometric formulation then I made a cut
forget everything from before I start
now with this abstract definition I
reformulated both of Newton's laws in
the new language but now I need to start
from the I can no longer use what I had
before from Newton's laws in charts I
need from these from this reformulation
I had in this section I need to derive
what I had that's right and there is no
assumption on nabla being flat it's not
a flat connection I didn't require this
anywhere okay I only required this posit
so it's right we're coming the other way
down and you can now not look at this
derivation with these prejudices you
can't Crosslink them that's dangerous
right so okay so um so so the definite
statements are these that's my point
okay so that's the certified Atlas but
now look at this guy down here what on
Earth is this well once I saw this I can
see I could get the
idea no I could for convenience so it's
a
convention I could uh
parameterize just convention
parameterize the world
line by absolute time
so by the number by this number here and
then you find that what before was D by
D Lambda now is a * d by DT but for a
constant a so you can convert these
primes into dots if the dot is the
derivative with a down here let's do
this we do this twice so instead of
double Prime we get double dot with a
factor a
squared a prime and yet another Prime
both become dots with a factor a squared
a prime and another Prime both become
dots with a factor a squared a prime and
another Prime both become dots with a
factor a
squar and over
here you don't have an A squ but you can
now divide on both sides by this factor
a squ which is just the units unit
measure of time you use right
so the whole left hand side becomes free
of it and only on the right hand side if
you write down your Force law you need
to decide for instance a Newton's
constant on what units of time you have
seconds or or years or whatever uh so
there it survives somehow it's a choice
that is usually absorbed into
here okay fine so we have this equation
so we have that now here you have what
you would usually call the acceleration
but which isn't the acceleration because
what is the
acceleration all of
this all of this is the one and only
acceleration Alpha
component no summon in there alone or
any combination of summons that isn't
all the
summons is acceleration because none of
these terms by itself or if any of these
terms is
missing this no longer transforms as a
vector okay but acceleration is a vector
because if acceleration as a vector it's
a tensor if a tensor has Vanishing
components in one chart it has Vanishing
components in any chart but chart is now
a chart on space time for instance you
have a chart like this now imagine you
twist the chart like this in space time
what do you get you get a rotating
coordinate system but in space time it's
one chart one chart that's constructed
like this is a rotating coordinate
system in space it's one fixed chart in
space time isn't that clever or now you
can do this wiggle yeah and that's it's
that chart but it's one fixed chart in
space time describes the view of a
dancer right if you want the coordinate
system of a dancer who carries the
coordinate system with him or something
like this okay anyway not a single one
of these is an acceleration by all by
itself now what if we have the presence
of
gravity yes question I see uh when you
introduce this a factor I see on the
left side how a squ emerges but I don't
see on the right side it doesn't and I
divide it through yeah but then one a
emerged there I don't see
how there's an a squ ah okay now
it's okay so I forgot the square
yes symb for
acceleration this is an a it's a small a
I just use this Crypt a because I had an
index a over
there okay it's the a for acceleration
okay now let's discuss this very quickly
in the presence of
gravity these two guys we would set to
the gravitational force little F Alpha
right so that would contribute a term to
the acceleration due to gravity and a
term that cannot be transformed
away additionally there could be a there
could be also sitting in this guy in the
gamma Alpha zero so let's say there is
no gravity let's let's get rid of
gravity if there's gravity there's a
contribution here let's assume there is
no
gravity and let's indeed assume if
there's no gravity you know in Gravity
the only
that is non zero if you use the right
chart is this one you can make all the
others zero if there's no gravity you
could formulate this as Newtonian space
time is flat in the absence of gravity
Newtonian space time is flat right and
if there's gravity in a certain system
is this gamma you can reformulate this
also fully geometrically I spare you
this the point is in the absence of
gravity you have a coordinate system
where all the gamas vanish and you say
oh that's what we always said EX double
dot equals F Alpha by m in a system
without gravity and in a very special
coordinate system now let's assume this
case you go to this very special
coordinate system and you don't have
gravity this looks all normal but now
you get the idea let's view the same
physics in a chart that's Twisted in
this direction which is one chart in
space time and which we would call
intuitively a rotating chart right but
it could also stretch could do all crazy
stuff then of course in that chart even
though in the previous chart all the
gamas were zero all kinds of gamas pop
up and assume we use a stratified Atlas
this is not
affected now what do these terms mean
well this term is only spatial only
spatial indices it means you chose a
chart for instance a polar coordinate
chart so without using a twisted chart
you have this cartisian chart as you
would call it now you choose polar
coordinates in space but you leave time
untouched you did this a thousand times
in classical mechanics these guys appear
these guys appear they're the correction
terms in polar coordinates this doesn't
appear and this doesn't appear either
now you go to a rotating chart and in
order to really say what rotation is
rather than rotation dilation you
already need to establish a metric on
each spatial section we haven't done
that yet for a good reason because the
idea that each Spa absolute that
absolute space carries a metric is an
inertial system fiction in a non-
inertial system the geometry of spaces
is more complicated than a
three-dimensional metric geometry I'll
comment on that maybe in a second again
so anyway assume we can talk about a
rotating system finish in a
second this term here x do0 in a
stratified chart there will be no more X
dots and this one will go
to this one here will be a term that's
independent of velocity but will depend
on what we usually call the rotation the
angular frequency of the rotation of the
chart this will be the centrifugal what
is usually called the centrifugal pseudo
acceleration this here has a two here
it's proportional to the velocity to the
spatial velocity of the particle it will
have the Omega in it too I mean you can
do much more complicated stuff than
rotating the Omega in it too this is
with an Omega and with an with an x dot
and the Omega may come in various ways
this is the CIS pseudo acceleration look
at Wikipedia how you get the
two okay uh I don't understand that
argument but the point is the two is
because the G the space time has no
curve has no torsion it's because of
these two terms appearing twice okay
that's the true of the Coralis Force
which really is hard to explain usually
you have to have to do some hand waving
the centrifugal pseudo acceleration and
the centrifugal and the coralist pseudo
acceleration why do you call them pseudo
accelerations well because you feel
something isn't quite right about them
as an acceleration of course there isn't
because neither this is an acceleration
nor that is an acceleration not that
what you're absolutely certain of is an
acceleration but only this one plus this
one plus this one is an acceleration now
in a rotating system this will no longer
be zero if before you had a uniformly
free moving
particle this will not be zero anymore
and this will not be zero anymore but
the sum of these will remain to be zero
because it's the acceleration of the
particle who doesn't care whether you're
thinking about a rotating coordinate
system or not
right the acceleration is totally
unimpressed
by your fantasy about what coordinate
system in
SpaceTime you
have that's all thank you very
much if there are no questions uh we
reconvene at a quarter
past there is a question
okay uh you were assuming that the
tortion is zero as one of the additional
yes I mean I understand that this makes
this nicer
here but we didn't get that out of the
first half of the lecture of
the there we didn't need it because we
assume first all the gamas are zero and
then we were forced to see some are
not the the first was coming from
prejudices to a certain level of
understanding and then saying in order
to get rid of all the the dead bodies we
left on the side of the road I didn't
talk about uh pedagogic omission of
truth I then formulated the next section
where I come top down and everything I
said before I said to give you an idea
how you get there and what is said in
this last section is the definite
formulation you should give Newton's
words so I I initially thought about
starting the lecture with the last
section but that is somewhat abstract if
you haven't understood the idea before
why you would even be prompted to go
there and you would get the idea well if
I do everything in a special chart then
everything was fine anyway this is all
unnecessary sophistication for S
sophistication sake the first part was
to say let's start with what we always
think is the right way to present it and
let's see where the problems
lie but then we need to have a fresh
start this is the Fresh Start I don't
think we need because we talking only
the which are not impressed by anyway
they
are the auto parallels are impressed by
torsion there it's dangerous if you have
a metric compatible connection which
comes in the next lecture and uh you add
torsion or not the autop parallels are
impressed okay um you say they're not
impressed because you have a symmetric
contribution from both there that's
right it depends on where you start and
what exactly you require in which order
uh this is a notoriously confusing
statement that torsion does it or does
it not affect Auto parallel the auto
parallel equation the answer is it
depends on how you define uh the
connection starting from given
structures in one way it depends in the
other one it doesn't depend although by
just staring at the equation you say the
antisymmetric part falls out but the
question is does already the symmetric
part have a torsion squared in it by
some construction
mechanism we just postulate it then
everything works out like like we like
it and the same is true in in Newtonian
in in Einstein gravity you require that
the connection you use is torsion free
and you have a um compatibility
condition not to the time function but
to the lorenzian metric of SpaceTime
which philosophically replaces the time
function is just that the uh the
sections it makes are no longer like
this but they're like the cone and
everything here is time like and
everything here is space like right uh
and here this was space like and this
was Tim like and everything this was and
so on okay but the lorenzian metric is
not the generalization of the spacal
metric you can think of it that way but
it's particularly non- insightful to do
it's the generalization of the absolute
time
function thank you very
much okay right suppose I'm in a rocket
and I turn on the engine turn off the
engine then Force depends on time so how
should I use the Newton Second low in
this case then I cannot or what happen
well I said it's a spatial Vector field
that means that DTF is
zero but I said f is a vector field on
space time so I don't see why it
wouldn't change if you proceed in space
time it's just it doesn't have a
component pointing there so say if I
draw a little picture say these are the
equal time surfaces um then I say the
force points like this it doesn't point
out but of course at another point it
could be different so you're just
switching off the rocket and now you're
switching it on again agree so that is
captured of
course any more
questions yes it's I have an idea this
formation you can very EAS
equations how you get in this the Gran
equations yes you can't before you do
not understand how to um establish a
metric on the spatial sections because
in the O lran equations they invariably
take the form like this some books say
in most systems they take this form no
in all systems uh the point is the G the
T here uh
is the velocity to the spatial Cur curve
okay uh 12 M um and you need a metric on
space to do this okay and when the book
thinks it doesn't have the form of the
standard T well it's just a
transformation of the components of this
G in other charts like polar coordinates
so neon mechanics always the lrin has
this form and this T has this form
without the square root because on Space
Newtonian uh LR formalism works over the
spatial section only um because uh if
you put the square root you have
reparameterization in variance you get
straight curves but not straight uniform
curves if you take this away you fix the
parameter automatically you get straight
uniform curves that's the reason for the
kinetic energy being like this without
the square root to get straight uniform
curves rather than straight curves but
this is a solid spatial picture this
doesn't work in the space time and it
cannot work in the space time as I said
because only in inertial systems which
by the way are uh defined as uh
coordinate frames XA d by
dxb uh by coordinates that satisfy this
these are inertial frames uh non
accelerated non- rotating is this um
because only in such frames where you
then have the uh equal time functions
can you establish a spatial metric
everywhere if you go to a rotating
system well phys in physicist intuition
tells you if you go to a rotating system
what do you need to know you need to
know the Omega Vector the frequency
right well it's actually Omega Co Vector
because it has to do with rotation in
Planes but apart from the G which is a
two tenser in space you need a one form
to know what's going on so in fact the
geometry is given by a metric and this
this Omega and stuff like this so really
having a metric of space is an inertial
system fiction and in an inertial system
uh you can make this working and running
and then you can by calculational truth
but zero structural Insight you can
change coordinates to depend also on the
time t Okay the formula of lran
mechanics stay true but it's somewhat
out of the initial formulation of LR
mechanics to go to rotating frames and
then you pick up all these terms and so
on but you don't really understand
them
okay so there their lectures in German
on the web on my classical mechanics
lectures that's a second year
undergraduate lecture um where I follow
this approach to introduce classical
mechanics and I finally come to lrin
mechanics uh that's in German is on the
web so if you want more on this this is
kind of some I don't know 40 hours
lectures
okay I I I'd say we we stop here and we
reconvene at a quarter past